you
this morning's I honor sixteen-year-old
climate activists Greta tune Berg joins
us for her first live us television
interview the teenager made headlines
last year with her solitary strike
against climate change
outside Sweden's Parliament she's
inspired millions of supporters to rally
in more than 150 countries Greta
recently sailed across the Atlantic
Ocean in a zero-emissions yachts she
landed here in New York where she'll be
speaking at the UN's climate action
summit later this month and Greta joins
us at the table Greta good morning good
morning
glad you made it you your message for
world leaders is that it's time to panic
and you want them to panic what do you
hope happens next
I mean of course by panic I don't mean
literally panic but that we and that
especially they step out of their
comfort zone because the planet is
outside its comfort zone and we also
need to be outside our comfort zone to
prevent the worst consequences from
happening and what I want people to do
now is to is to become aware of the
crisis that is here and that I I tell
world leaders when I speak to them and I
I tell them how it is how I I tell them
the science and how it looks like and
what you said you said that you said to
us a moment ago you want to push them
against the wall to shame them you said
those who who need shaming and it's that
I have been doing for quite a while now
and it actually has a lot of impact when
you speak like truth to power when you
don't bother to be polite because this
is such a serious crisis and you cannot
we cannot focus on with what we can or
cannot say now we must speak clearly
about what is happening I'm wondering
Greta what gave you the confidence to do
that that's what I was wondering - yeah
I don't know I just know what is right
and I want to do what is right I want to
make sure that I have done anything
everything in my power to to stop this
crisis from happening to prevent it and
and that and that ayah promise myself
that I I will do everything I can and
that is what I'm trying to do and also I
have I have Asperger's I'm on the autism
spectrum so I don't really care about
social codes that way in fact you called
your Asperger's you called it a
superpower a gift what do you mean by
that yes in some circumstances it can
definitely be an advantage to have some
kind of neurotypical diagnosis and to be
neurodiverse and because that makes you
different that makes you think
differently and especially in such a big
crisis like this when we need to think
outside the box we need to think outside
our current system that we need people
who think outside the box and who aren't
like everyone else and this began as a
one kid hunger strike in Sweden no
strike no school strike school and now
you have now you have millions of kids
around the world following you what's it
been like to watch that change it's been
very surreal because I think no one
could have predicted that and least of
all me so it has just been an adventure
seeing all these the things that have
been happening and to see all these
millions of children school striking for
the climate demanding a future saying
that why should we study for a future
that that is being taking away from us
when we are not doing anything to stop
what's the one thing we could do Greta
today all of us who are listening to you
I think the most important thing to do
right now is to try to understand the
crisis is to grasp the problem
because I think that once you fully
understand the climate and ecological
emergencies then you know what you can
do as well right and of course there's a
lot of things you can do in your
everyday life but we cannot be focusing
on these individual things you can do we
have to see the full picture
very good ID forgive me for interrupting
but we have to go thank you so much for
joining us this morning and your walked
here we should tell people she walked
here this morning all right